This is civil servant. That i was immediately. In a small town there in northern italy.
To out of the wife or minister
or do you what the actual town was called a battle for you here preaching from your parents. On the twenty seven.
January diet until its winter in january.
And i was very sickly and i don't expect me to really reflect
but mr came downstairs to greet me because my mother told me.
And when i was in italy my knowledge to tell me that you remember when i was born.
And my father came down that morning. And he said not yet. And this is true because.
Well as a private haven't showed him to have all together. Actually servants a lot of them. And i saw.
One of the eyes of the nun. Actually she would have been my oldest children.
To raise or she was a man she darted twenty yards in the corner and. Now i don't remember in utah.
What perspective they had in the family. That is firing me remembering.
If i can remember my mother sort of sighing and i have very strict catholic church was. To avoid morris.
Well i had enough for about coming out to.
My sister to tell me that the other guy or been trying and i don't remember anything about the trip.
But our remembers me and my brother jack. That of course my mom was having a little bag. In my hand and some.
And she said you only two weeks. So he was already. Twenty seven.
My father came out of that we had no idea what was the attraction. Did he have the traction. To get out immediately.
Because a lot. Was very high the younger brothers and sisters coming on so that the. Two boys really.
Because they were the ones that were great and i think immigration to us from what. Do you think that.
Just imagine a mother with two weeks out by one of her oldest son. But i think you could condition.
Another why was probably late school or twelve. And i would be put out. To a magical place.
Or to a friend supplies and from and. Probably for we're lucky to get a change of pliers.
But that meant that the family didn't have faith in them. That's what they need. Now instead of better in mind right.
Kind of attractive. With the intention to bring. To bring the whole family. That's how they planned it.
At the time he had been working on mostly. You know. We have a wonderful. Creek or he was in sydney.
And he came straight to me. And that's what brought you yesterday. He was the original one.
Very very hard to get to you know i hope to learn from. Quickly so that when we come out.
It's great that your daughter. Very much. Except that he had to go.
Which was very very very hard work to do for the series and he went doing them for.
Kind of iraq and actually had to get back to italy. And the family actually. Which will accept.
My brother and my sister. And your mother. You know.
My sister's or i can remember having that when when the very same brother. Do you remember your grandparents. You know.
Not at all possible. I wouldn't. Couldn't you do you know much about them through. My brother. My father.
Like that or there were only two in the family. He had one brother which was a very very small family.
I don't think they use contraceptives. By the way. I just think i have them but.
My grandmother didn't produce any more. So there were really world. Sort of.
And they had to and my uncle and he had two boys come to my mother.
My mother was a very good grace nightgown hair she kept the family going along the line dressmaking.
What she would do nicely. She would for the rich people of this. And there were a few around. There will be.
That woman to leave and she would go into the. Interest might take him. But she was breastfeeding. And the others were.
With a sister in law. Because the family. Common to have forty people in the one house. That is the.
Grandmother grandfather mother married son married sons
and their children will be having the time of one this particular one. Had triplets. Life was very hard.
And of course you wouldn't think of the children.
So she was just at the end of the terrace
or she went to the priest to ask for a company which is what they are you know that gave me a nice chat phrase that
they have to carry the cross. And she was trying his cross van and.
She got the count but wanted to have come from very close.
Quite with a very young woman that i suppose i'm going to get back on going back now
and i should get back to where we were hearing this. They want to go on. She was very young. She never thought.
They were very short. Two weeks. Just about the last one of them. I was on the gun nuts. Which was cool.
The coffee the coffee grounds and coffee. When i can remember my mother because we had children. Jack.
Winter not like them could we have some some right now how hard can we having to separate the dairy farmers
and taunt the. Coming. Country from. Rather and more dragging. Material. To build a house on the whole.
Because there was no right to live this way that was being put on this law and that. From.
Quite a few try and contact with military. So this country really comes to come to me and.
So that must be a problem for me because i'm going to help build a house was my dream that would just one top of the.
There was no law and of course. We had one. Which was not attached to the hair that. We had to carry the.
Into the bathroom and cool. It was cool that we had to actually go into the house and really going to kitchen bathroom.
It was a washed out of town and.
Some rather got married and he took my life my lawyer saw for a long time on something.
And because she has it all down larisa just pointed out in a bottle tea kettle that i can come up with some must drive.
The car. Critters. Such a. Lot of time and. So i got the tour. That night. Of our. Country called.
The last night which was running a lot better. That. Comply now i think that life was so much easier here.
Life is so much easier for the poor people in australia because i don't have a major crisis
and i don't think any of us. Actually had until we came to a strike me we're always in my power to mike.
A lot of guys are still have the implements that i've been out here
or in here that are probably asking for it no one else interested.
He wouldn't try and clone the pram dressed like children dressed in a beautiful red dress and become you know the boys.
And we all know. Except for mike you just do it so much on the very much what she looks right.
I kind of remember a fact that she lost in stride why she didn't tell you that we took our question.
In the word a really lot of italians here at the time because. The second family.
Has a family here kind of the first one was bad that they had come to yet. Actually through.
My last year in the family life. We have not had a close knit. Italian community with sort of brain.
Because we have a nominee for a why. We sort of haven't had a lot. With italian. When we first wind up.
We didn't have right or wrong. Having a family the kind that was interesting.
And that's my no you certainly am marrying one of your own son. But not very far away there was a kind.
And there was a local carrier there used to take them. But come to light on them but they were on your stride.
It was dr. What kind of business.
Well i'm sure i just remember the first day that my brother and my father would have had a vegetable garden. I'm sure.
Some thought might want to chill out and would have very little made such that we would have had chicken chicken.
We would have might have nothing right. That called out and this is a very good level of care.
Within my life so much simpler for us because it was really a lot of lawn.
That would probably would have been there but having gone doing them.
You would that we got a little bit of money that way and. Having a side that. Have it.
And if you go with the back of course what you did was put the lads be sure to do. Much with. When the crane kind of.
Top you would skim some of the cream out but not all that matter. Where you would mix a cherry.
And i have that with my. What was left with my recorder and very it was claimed that it was them.
We have would you call them. Droids you had the much.
You that work when there were nothing bad would suddenly have pressure you and the rest were to go with this.
That would last all year then when i called some of them. Some of them being near the salad. And the rest.
So that the individual that grew. It was really a tasty meal. And also full of vitamin. Much needed vitamins.
Yes we have a machine which is the one. I have now actually turned them around. My sister and. I have made next to you.
And we also. And tonight the brave are used and i get at them a kulak. If you get something from a contemporary jacket.
I should know more about that but i guess. From what i've seen.
I want to know what would you probably read
when you hit me you'll probably agree which you would not embrace that isn't good enough. But that wasn't half of the.
What we had to do which annoyed me that it was that when i was ready to need.
Having we were big family and we used to probably end you might get every two or three day.
You know that we had a two three clear. And i met. One i mean. Would be to create.
With about three of them and or through a long. Handle.
And it took two people one person would turn the dow up and one person would go up
and down with a handled that way that was pushing the very man and the handle kind. It would need it.
And i don't mind job. With that handle and i live with it working hard work but it just annoyed me and.
I don't i why i just hated that differ actually i don't know if you are going to hide it it was probably later on
because i was young. Or that we had to take home. My brain just grew and. I wanted to be like everybody else.
I hated my. Very endearing. I'm a male. That's a little knew what was that. But i really like that my brain.
That's what you try to school. Oh yeah. That's what we had we used to buy the tree the flag. Much that.
Should go it's kind of cool. You have that have to be brought up by the carrier and gone and picked up with two.
Better. Kind actually. You know it's coming into my. I think that's already out. When they're calling.
But you haven't read the lot. That's what they call them.
She knew all about that because it was very much larger than what they used in my political career.
That we do a lot of you know with a lot of. Years just a lot.
And if you want to turn it into a member you just might have something that will just. Race. To to. Remember the brain.
Can. Would have been phrased. How that would have probably gotten a good living. Praise the kind. Really cool.
The problem. A lot we have learned from this trying to create the barack who used to write.
Or how you put up with the top of that name and did. That work with a batter like that to actually turn a corner.
Did you have to. Actually google this one on how much not affect on you. But. I have a lot. But help. In the cheap.
Rascals. When you write at all. Little boy and all. I had to help. And the life that. I think i would have been a week.
And went up the hill. People that my brother knew. Right now. Because he came. And i'll never forget it.
Because the club.